you're not gonna believe this people but
uh drug companies are paying doctors can
you believe it yes every commercial that
you see is well actually a fake doctor
usually in the commercial and then a
half hour of symptoms and potential
suicide thoughts of suicide diarrhea
vomiting all that good stuff uh but a
federal website has come out with some
information related to just how much the
drug companies are paying doctors and
we've got some info for is let's take a
look alright so this is from ProPublica
and this is the amount of doctors that
each of these companies have been paying
now that's nothing new and there are
some reasons that that can be good they
have to figure out you know if these
things working you sometimes need
doctors do that the website who's 4.4
million payments to more than half a
million healthcare professionals from
august to December of 2013 adding to 3.5
billion dollars in the pockets of the
doctors and we've got a little more info
for you so this is sales and speaker
fees so Novartis yeah they had 19
billion dollars in sales in 2013 and
they paid out 13 million dollars
astrazeneca they made less paid out
almost double and forest I think is kind
of interesting on four billion dollars
they paid out the most 32 million so we
see these things all the time and
something about it inherently I think
seems nefarious doctors being paid by
drug companies but sometimes I think
there are reasons as I alluded to there
is you need some doctors to be involved
in putting together the drugs you
already shaking your head no but I'm
going to go to Lisette first is there
some before we get to the dangerous part
of this that we all know about is there
sometimes a reason that doctors and drug
companies do have to be kind of in
Connecticut I think medical device
companies and pharmaceutical companies
would say sure absolutely we need to
educate other doctors you know we need
an expert dr. to educate other doctors
about a particular product or a device
and in some cases yet it may have some
benefits right if the doctor was
involved in in the design of a
particular medical device true you
should educate other doctors on how to
use it unfortunately though what happens
is that these doctors are oftentimes
paved outrageous sums of money some
hundreds of thousands of dollars to give
talks and that's where I think it gets
really tricky and where there's there
could potentially be a conflict of
interest now I think
to further this research coming out of
the Affordable Care Act or the Sunshine
Act that is saying we have to have this
data one thing that's missing though is
to know in which cases there is a
conflict of interest in which there is
not so if a doctor for example is
involved in a particular medical device
is that dr. using that device on his or
her patients that's those types of
questions we need to be asking to
determine a conflict of interest right
and we of course we want to believe that
our doctors are doing things that are
scientifically sound and ethically sound
and you know abiding by their oath but
when you start getting paid a lot of
money and then you have two choices of
drugs while the guys that are paying you
you might start pushing them sure what
I'm in a temperate just a little most
doctors are paid between like two and
three thousand dollars for a speaking
fee which is a pretty standard speaking
feel like I know that sounds crazy right
but that's like how much an author would
get paid for you're not inherently doing
something bad for two grand if they
you're saying if it was a million
dollars you might be more no I'm just
saying like let's temper this a little
bit it said most doctors aren't paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars to go
and give a talk and and and most of the
money is going towards speaking fees but
also towards dinners towards the gifts
towards things like that I think the
fundamental problem here is that we
don't have strong regulation trying to
separate the powers-that-be between
physicians pharmaceutical and medical
device companies and the insurance
company there's like a large kind of
medical industrial complex that happens
in this country and I mean just as a
point of reference we are the only
Western industrialized nation that
allows pharmaceutical commercials on
television yeah no other country in no
other country is it legal to have a
commercial for a pharmaceutical that's
something that a doctor should recommend
to a patient we shouldn't be shopping
for pharmaceuticals we shouldn't be you
know we shouldn't be directly marketed
toward and I think that this is another
place where there's a lot of conflict
that comes in but it's only because the
system allows it I don't specifically
blame doctors I also don't really
specifically blame pharmaceutical
companies this is the culture in America
and it's perfectly legal to do so and
because it's perfectly legal to do so of
course they're going to try and get a
leg up by doing so it's easy for me to
sit back and go that's immoral but on
the free market are they really going to
care about whether or not it's more
right till that that's the kind
interesting parkas you really can't
blame the doctors for taking the money
which is legally can't blame the
companies for paying them because that's
also legal it doesn't make it right I
don't know but what this reminds me of
was I once went to a psychiatrist to get
I think I've talked about this on the
show before to get xanax to when I cuz
when i was on a plane I was getting uh
and I was freaking out low stress xanax
he then wanted to prescribe some other
drug to me for time shift disorder which
now I've google it's not even a real
disorder and he had a tape dispenser on
his desk with the name of the company on
it I mean I kid you not i mean i've
bought weed from guys the weed guys
never tried to sell me other drugs but
the Sun you know we got no anyone's
Marilyn know but that's what these guys
are doing and isn't that their the
that's the inherent that's everybody's
fault it's the doctors fault for being
overzealous and and literally the
freakin tape dispenser yeah it's a
systemic issue we're putting profit
before health and that's what needs to
change because if that doesn't change
we're going to continue to have issues
like this one and many more and we're
not going to get adequate health care
this is why we have such terrible health
care for being one of the most you know
developed nations for being such a
wealthy nation we're down at the bottom
in terms of quality of health care and
outcomes and that that's a problem
that's true i think we actually have
very good health care in this country i
think it's incredibly expensive i think
that we're very low ranked on how much
people are saddled with lifetime debt
because of health care but we have some
of the i mean we have world-class
healthcare in this country but it's
still it's still depends how much money
you have right yeah to some extent yes i
mean we do have the Affordable Care Act
now which is not not the Silver Bullet
by any stretch it's a stepping stone I
think once we can get to a single-payer
system we're going to see some
improvement but but yeah we definitely
have good health care in this country
it's just ungodly expensive and that's
because it's just not well I mean I
personally think it's because it's just
not well regulated yeah that that's a
whole other topic arts the last thing on
this is this just more reason why we
should be legal because
right now you got a headache so gvid a
bit of a jump bit of a scientific job
but really all these prescription pills
that every time I watch these
commercials and all that stuff diarrhea
vomiting all that and we do you know any
me like it doesn't have any and actually
smoking weed if you have a headache I
think that's the one thing weeds
actually not gone or not it tends to
make your head a course but it's weeds
not a cure-all I don't like it when you
see people in the in the movements and
fixes everything above but it is a
completely viable medication there's
absolutely no reason that it should be
scheduled and it should definitely be
available for patients to be able to
take marijuana for specific symptoms I
will I personally think it should be
available for recreational use to
because it's not [ __ ] dangerous but
it should for sure be one of the options
available